let's dig a little bit deeper into what
happens in perfectly competitive markets
in the long run
so what we have on the left-hand side
and we've seen this multiple times
already is our supply and our demand
curves for our perfectly competitive
market and you can see the equilibrium
price right over here marked with this
dotted line and as we've talked about in
multiple videos the firms in that
perfectly competitive market the
perfectly competitive firms they just
have to be price takers so the market
price is going to be their marginal
revenue curve it's going to be this
horizontal curve and it would be
rational for them to produce the
quantity so they're not going to set the
price but they can choose what quantity
to produce but it would be rational for
them to keep producing while the
marginal revenue is higher than the
marginal cost up to including when the
marginal revenue is equal to the
marginal cost so for this firm at this
current state of affairs it would be
rational for them to produce this
quantity right over there
and as we've talked about in other
videos at that quantity they're going to
make an economic profit and the way that
we can see that is at this quantity this
is the average total cost that is your
marginal revenue and so you are going to
get
this much per unit and then you multiply
so the height is how much you get per
unit and then you multiply that times
the number of units
so the area of this rectangle is that
positive economic profit that this firm
will have
now that's in the short run but now
let's think about what will likely
happen in the long run
if folks see other folks making a
positive economic profit remember
economic profit doesn't just account for
regular costs it also includes
opportunity cost so a lot of people say
hey i would want to put my resources
into this market so that i can make that
positive economic profit as well but
what's going to happen as you have
entrance into this market
well that's going to shift the supply
curve to the right at any given price
you're going to have more supplies one
way to think about it so if that's
supply curve let's just call that one
now you're going to have more entrance
more
entrance
and what's going to happen well you
might get to something like you might
get to a situation like
this actually let me see if i can draw
it well
you might get to a situation like this
where you have more entrance and you go
to supply curve 2.
now what's going to be the quantity that
firm a produces in that world remember
firm a is just one of many firms
well in this situation we have a new
equilibrium price so if this was p sub 1
now we have this new equilibrium price
p sub 2 which is going to define a new
marginal revenue curve for all of the
players in this perfectly competitive
market and so the new marginal revenue
curve is going to be right over there
now in this situation what is the
rational quantity for fermata produce
well once again as long as marginal
revenue is higher than marginal cost it
makes sense for them to produce more and
more and more up until the point that
they are equal so now firm a would want
to produce
less
because the market price that it just
has to take is less
but notice what happens as more and more
entrants got into the market the market
price which also defines this horizontal
marginal revenue curve went lower and
lower lower to the point where firm a
now in this situation is making no
economic profit at this point
we not only is marginal revenue
intersecting marginal cost but that's
exactly at the point at which marginal
cost is equaling average total cost so
one way to think about it is in a
perfectly competitive firm they are
productively efficient they are
producing the quantity that minimizes
their average total cost we've already
talked about that point where marginal
cost and average total cost intersect
that's going to be the minimum point for
average total cost and why is that well
while
while our marginal cost is below average
total cost average total cost is going
to get lower and lower and lower and
then once marginal cost gets higher than
average total cost well then the average
total cost curve will start going
curving up so we just saw a situation
that even where we see economic profit
in the short run in the long run
entrants are going to go into that
market and it's going to reduce the
economic profit down to zero and at that
point the firm that has that zero
economic profit they are productively
efficient they are producing at the
minimum point of their average total
cost curve and we've already talked
before that this equilibrium point right
over here in our market because our
demand and supply curves
are the intersection point is the price
defines the price our equilibrium price
and quantities we are also allocatively
efficient we've talked about things like
deadweight loss in the past that is not
happening right over here our marginal
benefit is equal to our marginal cost
right at that equilibrium price and
quantity now some of you might be saying
well
what about the other situation what
about if if for some reason we were in a
let's call it a supply curve three let's
see people overshot too many people
joined into this market so let's say we
went to supply curve
three well what's going to happen and
let me label this this is right over
here this is marginal revenue curve
one which is equal to price one this is
marginal revenue curve two which is
equal to price two and then this would
define so this right over here would be
price three
price three which would define marginal
revenue curve three
so marginal
revenue curve three which is equal to
price three well if too many entrants
joined into that market now firm a has a
more difficult scenario
they are would produce at this quantity
we've talked about many times already
but at that quantity
each unit their average total cost is
higher than that revenue they're getting
so they're going to be running at an
economic loss in the short run but what
would happen in the long run well firm a
in the long run would probably exit the
market and other firms who are running
an economic loss would exit the market
and so that would shift the supply curve
back to the left and so we would
eventually get once again to that
reality where firms have no economic
profit in there and we have a market
that is allocatively efficient no
deadweight loss and firms are producing
at the minimum point of their average
total cost curve which is known as
productive efficiency or productively
efficient